uh i'm gonna move some more company how
about you
yeah of course let's just talk to people
you know this face oh look at that smile
i have missed that
smile jane mcmanus
the pride of marist college my boss for
a second
i don't know if i would have set up a
sports communication at marriage you
hired me for a semester
you heard me you know didn't feel like
you're a phenomenal writer
yeah it was a fantastic semester working
for you working in your department at
mary's college i met a lot of great kids
will says hi in particular um
yes uh the whole whole class was great
whole group was great and a phenomenal
columnist for many years currently at
dead spin loving reading your work there
relatively new career move for you
um what should we start with first of
all how are you doing how is your family
how are you
handling the pandemic how's everybody
doing uh in court still in quarantine
kinda sorta
yeah i mean aren't we all of ha like not
quite sure exactly i mean i'm not going
to raves every night anymore
like that's been cut off um yeah but
it's different you know
we're on campus and so students have to
wear masks when they're not in their
dorm rooms and the classes are socially
distant i'm i'm holding my
my sports and culture class outside
where we can all be together at least
even though we're all masked and we can
have a conversation but i just
things don't quite feel normal and i
mean i think i mean i think that's kind
of reflected even in the way we're
watching sports right like the ratings
are down and
i i think it's still kind of confusing
things are playing outside of season so
it doesn't really feel like the usual
season
and with college sports as well so i
just i don't know i mean we're doing
well
but i think we're all just kind of in
this limbo it feels like until
things are our lives get back on some
sort of schedule or track
what do you what's your take on on
college sports um you know coming back
we talked a lot about the big tens
return
predictably the pac-10 has followed suit
college basketball is back
jane i just feel like this is such a
such a setback
for the momentum of the empowerment of
historically and traditionally
exploited college athletes it's like
if this doesn't prove that they're
employees i don't know what does they
got access to technology and testing
that the rest of the student body does
not
they don't have a seat at the table when
it comes to negotiating and discussing
the protocols and yet they're being put
out there
to play is what we care about health and
safety in so much
as it you know affects your ability to
get out there and make us more money so
just generally speaking what's your take
on colleges
coming back in the midst of a pandemic
to sports 100
i feel that it's the one part of sports
where
people are not able to make truly
informed you know
decisions because they're not paid
they're not able to balance
the income versus the risk and i think
one of the things that's been
gratifying in a lot of sports as they
come back is that players get to make
that decision
they get to say okay this is worth it to
me i'm going to put the red
and you have football in particular is a
sport where a lot of those players are
going to have the quote pre-existing
condition
of a high bmi and that's one of the
things that this particular virus really
likes
is a high bmi and so i think to put
those players in particular out there
and say okay
you're going to be going out and taking
the risk because our economy can't stand
to not have
college football we need it too much uh
it is it's absolutely making them an
essential worker
i feel like there's there's no way
around that um and i think it does skew
the priorities of colleges like your
your priority should be to serve your
students
i didn't i mean i wasn't sure what to
make of the nba
and the wnba and mlb when they were kind
of planning their comebacks especially
when with mlb you had so many positive
cases and really outbreaks on teams but
they seem to have been able to figure
out a way to do it
that it feels like they've hit some sort
of status quo on it and that's
you know that's good i'm glad i was not
necessarily anticipating that was what
was going to be happening so
it's nice to be able to see that there
are not a lot of cases coming out of
that
college football you're dealing with
like rosters of
100 players you know and personnel and
they're all going back
into their classrooms which is the
point of having an education so to me it
just feels like college football in
particular and the way that it's come
about
it's just the case in point that our
priorities are a little messed up
when it comes to who we're getting back
how we're getting them back
why we're getting certain classes of
people back and not others you know
i'm i you know i know i know you have
kids
so you're in the same boat like my kids
are zooming into their classrooms from
their bedrooms
and to me it's just like we need to
figure out
as a culture kind of what's what are our
priorities
and who should we be getting back and
doing that rather than this business had
a lot of money so they can afford the
testing so they get to be back
you know that's a perfect transition
jane because you talk about those
priorities kind of
uh just kind of screwed up well this is
a story of
impeccable priorities we talked about it
yesterday maya moore i'm sure you've had
the pleasure of
of interviewing her and covering her in
the past uh whether
at uconn or in her pro career great
story
about her marrying someone she fought to
to
release from prison free from prison and
just her story
overall of taking time away from her nba
career
to pursue this goal just uh just i
wonder what
what you thought of both of these
stories and the culmination
of them yesterday right
i saw the news come across like my
twitter feed like so many
many people probably experienced that
yesterday and i was like what
oh it kind of like
made a little bit of sense there what
was happening and i'm not saying that
she didn't do it out of the goodness of
her heart and that it was not a genuine
connection and that's why they got
together but it did make sense a little
bit
that that was you know that she felt
that kind of ardent way about pursuing
um his in the injustice that
that he was facing that she felt that
personal connection to it and that that
made it a little bit more
uh important for her and i think you
know anybody who's ever
fallen in love with somebody or been in
love with somebody or felt like someone
was wronged or felt a connection like
that
you know it does add a little something
in the way that you
are thinking about it um so that was
kind of my
mind was like oh yeah oh okay that makes
sense but um
but i think you know she's somebody who
i and i did cover her when she was at
uconn i do remember i sat down once with
her and her mom
for an interview and um they both struck
me
as like just two of the coolest people
that i've ever encountered and so
for to see this happen i mean not
surprised you know not surprised that it
would come from her
and i remember thinking with her like
even as i was sitting down
you know those years ago thinking you
know this is a woman
who is bound for something big like
she's going to make a mark she's going
to be doing something huge i don't know
what that's going to be yet is it going
to just be basketball or is it going to
be more than that
because she just there's something about
her there's like she has a a presence
that i think is um that's impressive if
you're if you're
in her inner company so i was not
surprised um
i'm glad to see you know she's so happy
you can see
how happy she is in that interview yeah
just glowing uh before we let you go jay
mcmanus
um quick question what because you know
the professor of me is curious michael's
in academia as well
what you mentioned your sports and
culture class what's the conversation
that you guys are holding in on right
now in your sports and culture class
before we let you go
well this morning we had class we talked
about fans
and um fan culture and so we're kind of
following along with uh this textbook
that was written by andrew billings and
it's
a great book but i have to see so much
of it as obsolete now in the moment
of covid because our ability to be fans
has been disrupted
right tailgating is different gathering
together in community is different
going to bars is different sitting in
the stands like if you can do that
that's different too so all of these
different rituals
that we used to have around the way that
we consume sports
has completely changed and i know that
you know some people have have kind of
taken that interest online i mean you
know
speaking of russell wilson my fantasy
team does start him so i feel you know
i gotta jump on that one but um you know
it's just that the
so the whole a lot of a lot of these
rituals and cultures are kind of
moving online but that's not quite it's
not quite the same there really is this
physical gathering i think that goes
around sports and that's part of why
people
really connect with sports and their
communities and
um that whole thing has changed and so
we're having um
kavitha davidson and jessica luther to
discuss their new book on
saturday's class uh-huh about um loving
sports when they don't love you back
awesome see that's why i was so much fun
to work with you at marist last semester
i learned a lot i had a good time
so good to see you jay mcmanus thanks
for joining us from another my sister
from another mister thank you for
joining us that's right
thank you thank you come back anytime